payer des milliards dans un milieu de
terrain tout le monde me dit que c'est
le meilleur du monde encore ce soir il
était à chier et enfin sa bague de 52
ans qui lui a donné la leçon les
défenseurs marquinhos c'est le meilleur
du monde il a été nullissime ya zéro
humilité non pour la fashion week livre
/ tik tok qui font des trucs les autres
ne font pas dans les autres clubs on n'a
pas ça casse copé chez colas mois bande
de guignols mois ce sont tous des
guignols tous des guignols 0
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire un truc ya souvent un
problème à paris
c'est pas le psg c'est paris c'est qu'il
ya énormément de joueurs aussi qui vise
10 on va là paris parce que un pari on
va faire des soirées ça bouge grave et
on va pouvoir aller dans les magasins où
vas kiffer paris c'est une ville
exceptionnelle donc il ya aussi beaucoup
de joueurs qui viennent à paris pour les
mauvaises raisons et je pense que daniel
c'est ce que tu penses aussi un et
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dans ces cas
là cyril d'après toi eh ben il faut
changer de joueur
il faut qu'ils aient un patron ouais et
que le patron fasse attention à ce que
font les joueurs bien sûr est que la
république des joueurs ne s'installe pas
or au pg ça fait dix ans qu'elle dure
cette république des joueurs donc au
bout d'un moment le premier responsable
de ses échecs à répétition
faut pas chercher très loin c'est le
patron et qui est le patron du club
nasser al-khelaifi produits innovations
sable
je sais mais là encore je suis pas
sélectionné je ne suis pas d'accord avec
toi mais si moi je pense que nasser il
fait ce qu'il faut justement alors
mélodies tout faire et je le défends pas
parce que c'est mon ami si je le défends
je vais dire pourquoi nasser ces points
chauds je raisonne pas comme toi nasser
justement il le remet tout à disposition
un ajustement de valeur chercher les
meilleurs jouets justement ces livres
n'ont pas valeur chercher les meilleurs
joueurs où il dormait les meilleures
infrastructures
il fait tout pour les joueurs il met
tout c'est que et après pour moi le
responsable au rallye pour moi danser
main par l'entraîneur pour moi il ya un
responsable et en plus je l'adoré c'est
leonardo c'est le dire si ba si massy
parce que c'est lui qui choisit les
joueurs
méritent l'expliqué tour à leonardo tu
ne pourras pas avoir un entraîneur
français que j'essaie de te l'expliquer
avec un domaine que tu maîtrises mieux
que moi l'argent nord est et les non
dits une émission tu des années qui
marche très bien oui tu fais des belles
audiences l'été prochain tu décides pour
récompenser et augmente à tout le monde
a les trois fois le prix de la paix j'en
ai bien sûr daniel il est dans la
fiction 1 3 4 fois ouais mais bien les
prochaines les audiences se casse la
gueule tu comprends pas trop pourquoi
dans gears 3 il doit y avoir un problème
tu les remplacent à la fin de la saison
gay suffit bon ça marche toujours pas à
les rédacteurs en chef on change la
deuxième année du jour démarre ça marche
toujours pas pg ça fait dix ans que
c'est comme ça tu crois qu'au bout de la
troisième année cité audiences se casse
la gueule que tu passes derrière france
5 arte et gulli toutefois pas qu'il ya
le grand patron qui va descendre à fils
honnêtement je crois qu'à un moment il
faut se regarder dans une glace c'est
peut-être tout le problème ça marche
plus comme avant il sait qu'il ya un
truc qui s'est cassé il va me dire ça
ici
tu comprends ce que je veux dire 10 ans
ça non mais il a tout fait la misère se
regarder dans une glace à 6 min la spa
il ne peut pas tout shooté câliner
autant les joueurs intéressent tous fait
la série à partir mieux jeu c'est
quelqu'un qui impose une discipline hier
jean-claude blanc qui est extraordinaire
aussi le staff qu'il est magnifique je
te dis franchement moi pour moi le
problème je te le redis c'est que il est
parti il est revenu rien n'a été modifié
c'est les mêmes problèmes depuis dix ans
leonardo ils étaient là au début ça n'a
pas marché il est parti il a laissé sa
place à un autre antero henrique c'est
l'époque catastrophe remonte à da barca
il est revenu leonardo ça ne marche
toujours pas on change d'entraîneur tous
les ans tous les deux ans les mecs
partent ailleurs ils gagnent
libre il a gagné leur pari ouais mais
moi je suis je comprends bien qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose qui ne va pas
et à un moment il ya quand même des
questions à se poser ton ami nasser el
hafi moi j'ai rien contre lui mais prof
de tennis salue correspondait mieux non
je suis pas dirigeant d'un club il sait
pas faire il ne s'est pas fait mais pas
d'accès limité la casse rabelais très
sympa parce qu'il lui faut quelqu'un le
comme prof de théâtre mais moi seule
alors moi je pense un très bon président
et je pense tu nous manques il lui
manque quelqu'un en dessous d'ailleurs
un site urbain dans quelques années
voilà pour serrer la vis la piscine
c'est
une seule personne qui peut sauver ce
club et qui peut prendre sa place et
réussir c'est idéal moi
bah voilà maintenant d'annasr mais il
faut que nasser reste je te dis nasser
il est très important dans le club et
c'est lui qui fait venir les joueurs une
pile mais c'est pas lui qui les fait
venir il a un chéquier syrie c'est
facile de diriger quand un chien non tu
fais ce que tu veux mais au fait c'est
un chéquier à moitié
chéquier aussi large et qui peut à ce
point recruter c'est lui c'est facile de
dire aux gens quand tu prends ton chez
kate us justin tu si la série n'est
capable de gagner même choqué connais
rien au foot ici
daniel alors si on t'avait dit alors
bien sûr tu vas te dire je veux dire je
suis jeune et je le défends mais la c1
si on avait dit avant la c1 le psg
serait largement favori contre le real
madrid et on serait déçus que le psg
perd contre le real madrid avant
l'arrivée de nasser avant l'arrivée du
qatar au psg à marseille tu disais le
real madrid sur les batteries c'est un
exploit le problème c'est bodmer au sein
du psg aujourd'hui le psg je te dis ça
fait partie de la partie des plus grands
clubs mais si on favorise partiquement
contre toutes les équipes être humilié
chaque année parce que tu sais ce qu'est
en train de ce bassin ils ont fait une
finale une d'or et usé oui mais sur les
dix ans il ya trop il ya trop d'échecs
trop de fiasco il est en train de se
passer quelque chose de grave qui est
une étape très importante que ton ami va
devoir gérer c'est le rejet fondamentale
et culturel du pg c'est un club qui est
détesté par tout une roma daniele oui
aujourd'hui c'est plus froid et daniel
gilles sur glace et par les supporters
du barça qui déteste en real hier ils
ont fêté la qualif du réel non non ils
détestent
et parapublic volatiles gestion du foot
des tests vibrante les mairies peuvent
pas dur c'est pas ça quand même l'énième
en ville et 22 on s'en fout les ventes
domaniaux c'est des gamins qui achètent
les mamies ton fils est aussi
je te jure que j'en avais daniel juste
quand tu les traites de guignol oui est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec danièle
bessis pas bien daniel c'est pas bien
non pas vous mais si c'est ça qui me
semble assez juste de finir les serait
fini ces cas là cela dit jouer au poker
qui qui passe sa vie sur tik tok c'est
pas un jour de foot aujourd'hui ils
avancent plus sur le terrain il
franchement moi il me fait de la peine
quand tu fais de la peine l'idéal c'est
quand vous êtes à cours d'arguments et
ça me déçoit de deux heures d'émotion
c'est un morceau assez bas excusez moi
avoue défaut c'est vous
[Musique]
dire pas une map et après comme ici est
venue à paris vous en avez fait des 15
kilotonnes moi j'ai dû quitter les rangs
de l'émission à régler la mire gildas
laissez moi c'est bon merci tu vas pas
tu vas pas transformer ce que moi j'ai
plongé j'ai dit dès le début que c'était
une erreur de prendre mes 6 7 2 me méfie
non il a alors et non là je défend
daniel j'ai l'habitude daniel il avait
dit sur messi des conneries tu
appartiens démission daniel il a touché
tu vas pas quand même
après je vous dis c'est pas une connerie
parce que ç'a rapporté énormément
dessous en maillot je peux vous dire
voilà c'est bizarre en fait oui mais ça
a été énorme appareil à quoi ça sert
mais voilà bien sûr à quoi ça sert me et
c'est une entreprise aussi ben voilà
alors les vont perdre pas mal de sous
une entreprise de football et ensuite le
business vert sur les anglais font ça
très bien le real fait ça très bien
football puis business le mariage des
deux est essentiel aujourd'hui là n'est
pas équipé du lien entre eux et c'est
l'un et l'autre souvenir un truc daniel
oui c'est exact vous êtes dur quand même
avec avec nasser nasser il a fait un
truc énorme pour le club hier on avait
une équipe qui était quand même sur le
sur deux sur le franchement sur le
papier les énormes l'équipe mais
celle-ci à la mi temps ils mènent 1 0
tout le monde est persuadé qu'ils vont
qui sont et qui passe contre le real
s'est terminée que c'est jouer ça se
joue à rien et on ne serait pas si
aujourd'hui tout le monde aurait dit
matt avait le pgr maculé la halle c'est
normal ça je dis bien si c'est une fois
mais quand c'est tout le temps c'est
qu'alors toi tu tu fais du sport tu sais
ce que c'est si un match bon pas de je
connais moins de me voient parler tennis
tu connais très bien tu fais les
tournois six premiers tours tu gagne le
premier set est à chaque fois tu t'es
crawl et à chaque fois tu répètes sa
infiniment qu'ils ont à dire cirilli
mais mentalement il est faiblard il n'y
arrive pas mais je sais très bien non
plus comment problème mental et
remontait un problème physique aussi au
psg hier il est allé te tuer pourquoi
physique les mecs ont lieu au jeu ce
n'est donc pas la licence sur tictoc qui
joue enfin tu m'aurais killian kilian
est ivre et qui viennent à lessard
minable tu l'as d'écouté tt était en
train d où peut-être d'essayer de le
convaincre de rester casillas talibans
qui reste le premier s'est séparé ça va
être très compliqué ça va être très
compliqué alors qu'on était un peut-être
en train de basculer à ces morts là bas
qu'est celui qui a fait cela moi moi
s'appelait je suis dégoûté t'envie
dresser le tueur est à sa place ça il
faut laisser passer le voile à sortir de
l'émotion sens et géraldine pouvait
avoir ton avis moi oui non non ce qu'il
peut rester que si à zidane ancien
guignols c'est maintenant que c'est très
bien
[Applaudissements]